vous devez nous connaître ma soeur et
moi on a un passé chargé
on a failli mourir tué par une sorcière
maintenant on est fait pour tuer des
sorcières mais entre nous
7 j ai préféré porter ces deux dernières
semaines cinq enfants nous ont été
enlevés une sorcière ne se montre pas en
plein jour comme ça on affaire à autre
chose
il faut retrouver ses enfants je ne vais
pas vous laisser me dire ce que je dois
faire
c'est quoi cet endroit notre ancienne
maison nos parents nous ont pas
abandonnés ils ont été assassinés vous
avez enfin retrouver votre achat ne tire
sur tout ce qui bouge
ce boulot m'a enseigné une chose au film
touchez pas à ces [ __ ] de ballons
ça c'est nouveau c'est la gueule
quelle est la meilleure méthode pour
tuer une sorcière leur couper la tête ça
marche assez bien
la date est celle là